mariupol es una ciudad portuaria de
medio millón de habitantes y es ahora
objetivo constantes de los bombardeos
rusos fuerzas armadas llegaron desde
crimea para alcanzar este punto
estratégico mientras que los
separatistas pro rusos de dónetsk
rodeaban la ciudad sin mariupol cae en
manos rusas el kremlin obtendrá un
puente terrestre hacia crimea pasando
por las regiones del donbass tomaría
también el control total sobre el mar de
azov una ruta importante para los barcos
porque conecta directamente al mar negro
con un solo punto de entrada el estrecho
de kerch en 2018
el presidente ruso vladimir putin
inauguró un puente de 19 kilómetros
conectando la península de crimea con el
continente ruso atravesando el estrecho
desde entonces las tensiones han ido en
aumento las autoridades rusas ejercen
hasta hoy una presión continua sobre
cada barco que intenta alcanzar los
puertos ucranianos aunque moscú tiene el
control sobre quién puede entrar y salir
del mar y del mar negro la toma de
mariupol sería la última etapa para
poder controlar toda la región después
de haber anexado crimea en 2014 por
ahora las autoridades rusas suspendieron
toda navegación en el mar azov hasta
nuevo aviso más de 170 buques están
varados afectando las exportaciones de
trigo en todo el mundo